ALICIA: FOX NEWS GRIFF JENKINS
IS DOWN AT EAGLE PASS WITH TONY
GONZALEZ.
HI, GRIFF.
>> REPORTER: THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE'S BEEN 10 APPREHENSIONS
SINCE THE NEW FISCAL YEAR BEGAN
ON OCTOBER 1.
CONGRESSMAN, YOUR THOUGHTS.
WHY ARE YOU HERE TODAY?
>> THIS IS THE EYE OF THE STORM.
YOU KNOW, EAGLE PASS HAS BEEN
NONSTOP CHAOS FROM DAY ONE.
I DID A RIDE ALONG WITH THE
EAGLE PASS POLICE DEPARTMENT,
AND WHAT WE WERE SEEING IS STASH
HOUSE AFTER STASH HOUSE AND
THEY'RE SEEING AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF FENTANYL RELATED
CALLS.
THIS IS HAPPENING ALL OVER MY
DISTRICT BUT EAGLE PASS IS AT
THE CENTER OF IT.
>> REPORTER: CONGRESSMAN,
YESTERDAY GOVERNOR ABBOTT WAS
TOUTING LONE STAR AND
337 MILLION LETHAL DOSES OF
FENTANYL HEADING INTO FISCAL NEW
YEAR AND BETTER OFF OR GETTING
WORSE?
>> IT'S GETTING WORSE.
IT'S LITERALLY ALL HANDS ON DECK
FROM LOCAL PD TO THE SHERIFF'S,
COUNTY SHERIFF'S TO THE STATE.
BUT THIS IS A FEDERAL PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW, JOE BIDEN HAS CAUSED
THIS PROBLEM.
WE HAVE KAMALA HARRIS WHO'S IN
TEXAS LATER ON TODAY FOR A
FUNDRAISING EVENT.
IT'S A SLAP IN THE FACE TO THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE ALONG THE
BOARDER AND THERE WAS A CASE I
WAS LISTENING AND HAVING LUNCH
WITH A SHALL HAVE FROM ZAVALA
COUNTY AND A CHILD IN A BASEBALL
GAME GOT HIT IN THE HEAD AND WAS
SUPPOSED TO GET AIR LIFTED TO
SAN ANTONIO FOR CARE BUT THERE
WERE NO RESOURCES BECAUSE
EVERYTHING WAS PUT TOWARDS THE
MIGRANTS.
>> REPORTER: WE HAD YESTERDAY,
CONGRESSMAN, SHOWING OUR VIEWERS
THAT A AMBULANCES HAD TO TAKE
TEN NICARAGUAEN TO THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE OF A CAR ACCIDENT AND
BORDER PATROL HAD TO JUMP INTO
ACTION.
>> EVERY DAY AMERICANS ARE PUT
LAST.
WE DON'T FEEL SAFE, WE DON'T
FEEL SECURE, OUR CHILDREN ARE
GOING INTO LOCKDOWN.
WE JUST STARTED UP SCHOOL A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO.
A LOT OF MY SCHOOLS ARE GOING
INTO LOCKDOWN ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
THIS IS NOT NORMAL.
THERE'S NOTHING NORMAL ABOUT
THIS.
BIDEN AND HOUSE DEMOCRATS HAVE
FAILED US.
HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAVE A PLAN
AND OUR COMMITMENT TO AMERICA
AND PART OF THAT IS TO SECURE
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> REPORTER: HOW WILL
REPUBLICANS, 9/11 YOU TAKE THE
HOUSE AND THAT'S THE ONLY BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT YOU HAVE, HOW WILL
YOU MAKE A DIFFERENCE?
THE CARTELS, CONGRESSMAN, SEEM
TO HAVE ABSOLUTE CONTROL OF THIS
BORDER HERE.
>> RIGHT NOW, THE CARTEL TAKEN A
SMUGGLING INDUSTRY TO
$13 BILLION AND HOUSE
REPUBLICANS CAN DO THAT WITH THE
POWER OF THE PURSE.
I SIT ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND THEY LEAVE AND
HOLD THIS ACCOUNTABLE ANDED
ADMINISTRATION TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS.
>> REPORTER: WE'VE BEEN
REPORTING ON A TIKTOK VIDEO AND
ADVERTISING FOR A DRIVER TO
DRIVE FROM MCCALLEN TO HOUSTON
AND $70 THROW AND CARTEL TAKEN
TO SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> GRIFF, THE CARTELS ARE
CONTRACTING OUT TO GANGS AND
ORGANIZED CRIMINALS, AND THOSE
GANGS ARE SUBCONTRACTING IT OUT
TO EVERY DAY PEOPLE.
THAT TIKTOK VIDEO MAY HAVE BEEN
$70,000 ADVERTISEMENT BUT THE
CARTEL MAY BE GIVING THEM 150 IN
ORDER TO DO THAT.
WHY?
IF SOMETHING GOES DOWN, YOU'RE
SEEING EVERY DAY PEOPLE GET
IMPACTED.
I ASKED THE SHERIFF THE OTHER
DAY, WHAT DOES A SMUGGLER LOOK
LIKE?
HE GOES, TONY, IT'S EVERY DAY
PEOPLE NOW.
JUST IN THE PAST MONTH, THEY
CAUGHT FIVE NATIONAL GUARDSMEN
THAT WERE CAUGHT SMUGGLING AS
WELL.
>> REPORTER: WELL, NOT GETTING
ANY BETTER HERE.
CONGRESSMAN TONY GONZALEZ
MEETING WITH BUSINESS PEOPLE AND
I BELIEVE A FAMILY MEMBER, A
GRIEVING PARENT FR